l'actualité de ce samedi en France avec
d'abord la Marche des fiertés la
traditionnelle g Pride qui cette année a
pris un temps d'avance sur 2007 la
campagne présidentielle est déjà ouverte
sur un thème de société qui pourrait
faire la différence le mariage et
l'adoption pour les couples du même sexe
en tête de cortège François Hollande et
de nombreuses personnalités du PS Anne
Sophie chomier le compte
jean-mar défilé
au cou à coude avec les habitués de la
GU Pride François Hollande tente de se
faire une place en 1996 il était venu
défendre le
Pax je viens 10 ans après à la veille
d'une échéance importante pour dire que
sur la question du mariage nous
l'ouvrirons au couple quel que soit le
orientation sexuelle l'égalité pour tous
si la gauche à tranché est sorti ses
têtes d'affiche à l'UMP on préfère
envoyer les jeunes en éclaireur pour
pour la première fois le parti a même
financé un char l'UMP est un parti de
liberté certains s'expriment contre et
ils ont le droit de le faire contre le
mariage de gay d'autres s'expriment pour
nous sommes là et il n'y a aucune
schizophrénie loin des discours
politique Valérie et Vanda sont là pour
témoigner elles sont mamans de deux
enfants et militent pour être enfin
comme elles disent des citoyenne à part
entière on espère pouvoir se marier ça
fait 20 ans qu'on vit ensemble
donc donc voilà on espère que les
politiques vont un petit peu se
réveiller parce que la société elle nous
accepte plutôt bien mais les politiques
sont très en retard 600000 personnes
dans la rue deux fois plus que l'an
dernier le débat sur le mariage gay et
l'homoparentalité sera difficile à
occulter d'ici l'élection
présidentielle